[Musique]
buono
[Applaudissements]
ce soir je vous le dis grosse grosse
grosse inquiéta soit bas ils sont là les
mesdames ce chris pine
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
vous savez qui sied vraiment et demi son
ami ce grotte de lascaux
soixante deux ans à mettet poker sont
magnifiques à 62 ans vous regardez les
mecs qu'ils en ont 50 regarde les c'est
pas des paupières qui l'afer lui mon
frère il ferait déjà vu la d2 sous de
porto da place des jeunes dans ce que
vous avez à dire il ya la pub là notre
gagner de l'hôtel vous écoutez je vais
faire je vous le dit c'est le dimanche
soir qu'on fait des folies physiquement
parce que le dimanche soir on a rien à
faire était lui à 17h mon frère c'est
vrai on fait du tournoi c'est unique
qu'est ce que je vais europe et on va
rentrer dedans miroir délire tu vois pas
là je connais ça m'arrivait plein
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
épi est une bonne excuse verra hélas
tecomah c'était comme ça tu es dans la
salle de bain tu commences à prendre une
tondeuse j'ai fait son choix à faire tu
vas le faire un petit truc en masse tu
fais un tout petit et ses frères et plus
ça va plus je fais [ __ ] merde donc
sera d'ici montrer à la face je connais
par coeur
tu es devant le film de tf1 aura sera
d'enlever tu sais que le lendemain la du
time tout et mon frère de bouffe
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
et sur la tête de ma mère prochaine fois
je veux ni lever d'accord pas venir j'ai
plein de trucs à dire sur la littérature
est vous avez à dire par exemple un
abrupt pourquoi c'est ouf les livres
[Rires]
[Musique]
on est très très agitée aujourd'hui
ça fait mal
jennifer pan elle porte un tee shirt de
chedjou c'est une petite marque qui paye
pas de mine
c'est magnifique regardez alors ça
représente deux personnes qui s'aiment
au bord de l'océan
là je reconnais c'est l'article portait
un magnifique villa cet incident payet
j'aime beaucoup et là bien entendu
et bien voilà on est là j'ai besoin
camia les matières nobles après la
coupure ce que j'ai voulu faire
j'ai voulu faire coiffer décoiffer c'est
exactement ce exactement c'est ce que je
sais ce que j'ai voulu faire et vous
voyez bien il ya deux équipes au niveau
du cheveu des deux premières équipes qui
s'arrête ici il ya une deuxième équipe
qui est ici les deux équipes ne se
parlent pas ouais je dois à mes j'adore
il est sans moi j'adore on voit les gens
se taisent avoir déjà fait
[Applaudissements]
gr g joe biden
[Musique]
combien avez vous de sur instagram de
followers 800 1 5750
ouais c'est formidable et bah allez vous
que celle juste une question comme ça
quoi cet animateur humoriste aussi donc
assez compliqué parce que je suis dans
cette séquence on avocat des bleus
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
sépare du parti allez on y va
j'aimerais bien je sais pas si les
autres seraient d'accord rétrocéder 70
euros de mon salaire soudé soir qu'est
ce qu'il avait assisté à un spectacle
gratuitement comme ça je ne sais pas
honnête regardez les vous pourrez comme
ça ou payer des cours d'orthophonie
[Applaudissements]
après il y avait dragon sur gulli est
alors justement j'ai une question à vous
poser bien dragon c'est trop bien pour
moi je vais vous dire j'ai une question
posée aux téléspectateurs pourquoi vous
mettez des dessins animés
la nuit à 4 heures du matin veut y
croire vraiment il ya un enfant il va
ils veulent commence à carole m'attendre
elle regarda difficile et tranquille
chez lui tant il a déjà été tranquille
et là tu vois deux raisons après sa 14e
mais attention dans un album les pontes
des enfants ils sont comme on serait
presque à délibérer
à 4 heures du matin non mais si ses
jambes
pourquoi j'ai fait une flèche peu parce
que on sait bleus dans ma vie ces bleus
dans mon coeur mais dans la gueule de
quelques saluts les cultures salle une
étude salut
[Musique]
pour maquiller un peu vaccinés il est
blanc dirait mon cul vendredi soir j'ai
appris mon fils m'a bouffé tout le
[Musique]
des fois j'en vois des fleurs sans
raison c'est une pratique frère ne fait
jamais un trop gros bouquet grobari
égale quelque chose à te reprocher
heures petit bouquet je suis sympa ouais
j'ai rien fait je suis bien dans ma vie
prends mon portable toi plaisir est
aussi petit bouquet pour qu'on te voit
derrière
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]